I've been working for you know 15 years
as a stunt performer on variety of sets
all over the world
majority of the days you're fighting and
falling atomic bond I am so proud of
that movie so we had this stairwell
scene in this fight that in the script
was she shoots two guys but you know we
were talking today we're like hey you
know what if we do this epic fight scene
we actually went to the stairwell and we
shot it how we would shoot it on set so
we call this a previous a stunt previous
and then we have Charlize go in and
shoot this the first section until it
was good sometimes 15 to 20 takes for
each section because it had to be
perfect they put me in when it was the
you know throwing the gang throwing down
the stairs and getting thrown into the
wall and then back to Charlize is
section I'm so proud of that sequence I
think we really accomplished something
incredible she's beautiful but she is
tough she wants to be good she wants to
do everything and and she was there all
the time in the gym with us and you know
the Tom Cruise is and the Angela Jolie's
and Charlize and Keanu like they're all
very athletic and very talented the
problem is they can't do though all
their own stunts because of liability
and you know you can't you just can't do
that I got excited but I'm not nervous I
don't fear this done and I just go
through this doubt in my mind I make
sure everything all the rigging looks
good and then you just go okay cool call
action like I'm ready let's do this
so I probably worked for ten years
without my family really knowing what I
was doing now my mom works in film
though so she sees everything she once
brought me my grenade launcher that was
pretty hilarious like mom I need my
grenade launcher my story is I was I was
modeling and all the models were taking
acting classes and they were you know
being extras on set to make extra money
and and I saw this girl roll down some
stairs and shoot some guns and beat up
some dudes and I was like I want to do
that you know most of my training was in
the park by myself running and falling
over and over and over again until it
felt natural I had probably fallen
thousands of times sometimes I am the
only woman in the room there's
definitely a lack of female leadership
in our stunt industry so you know you're
falling but you're following in a skirt
all the time you know I go into the
costumes and I go no skirts we're gonna
do pants now but I think it's changing
and I was the first female stunt
coordinator that Marvel is hired as a
stunt coordinator you're taking on the
responsibility of designing all the
action the stunt action making sure it's
as safe as possible and then coming up
with some really creative way to to tell
the story through action the riskiest
stunt I think that I've done is in we're
shooting in Bulgaria and I was driving a
two-horse chariot at a full gallop I had
to jump from the chariot to the horse
and it was just me in the chariot
that was that one got me going like as
soon as they call to action like you
just you have to commit